هو متحف متحف تاريخي ويحتضن خطه تاريخيه
وعنا قاعه خاصه بالاديان السماويه كذلك
عنا قاعه خاصه بالمحرقه في عده قيمه لهذه
التوراه اول شيء طبعا التوراه من كتب
السماويه اللي يعني احنا نحترمها ثانيا
هاي المخطوطه كان المفروض انها تتلف خلال
فتره هجوم النازيين ايام المحرقه وكذا على
اليهود بعد هزيمه النازيه تم
العثور عليها المخطوطه التوراتيه لان
تعتبر التوراه كامله وتعتبر من الاحجام
الكبيره كذلك لها قيمه هذا الحجم كبير هذه
التوراه عمرها الفعلي اكثر عن 1870 سنه
وطبعا القيمه الاخيره ان هي طبعا كانت
بدعوه من ناشونال
في المملكه المتحده هي المؤتمنه على
الحفاظ على المخطوطات التوراتيه تواصلوا
معنا من خلال رئيس مستر جفري
طلب منا انه يعني يعطينا نوع من عهده
لمتحف بسبب وجود قاعه المحرقه فقالوا مهم
جدا التوراتكم موجود معانا لان كانت
تنقصنا التوراه التوراه متكامله
التوراه من الكتب السماويه واحنا عرف عنها
ولكن يعني عاده في الوطن العربي والاسلامي
ما تشوفين الرساله الثاني ان احنا عايشين
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
شمال افريقيا يعني لازم البعد الديني بعد
مهم كذلك البعد الثقافي والاجتماعي فهاي
التوراه تعبر عن يعني عن شقين شق الديني
وشق الاجتماعي
[موسيقى]